been waiting on his album for a very
long time yeah about three and a half
years
2019-ish but uh I bet that hey RJ's here
Mr L.A Michelle welcome man how you
doing my brother how you feeling now
that you got this body of work finally
into the world I know you've been
working on it for a long time you [ __ ]
with it I do I've I think you know
what's crazy I feel like that you are
the most consistent
outside of Kendrick because we gotta
Give It Up to cada but I feel like
consistency
when I know you drop I just know that
there's a certain level of quality that
comes with RJ do you think he [ __ ]
with me
I think Kendrick's [ __ ] with
everybody so that's you know just to be
I mean do you want me to lie to you no I
I'm honesty I just think like when I
think of like the city I'm like yo art I
just know I'm getting quality music from
RJ every [ __ ] go
timeless music and I think you're the
best performer uh I think your top five
performer in hip-hop to be honest
hip-hop yeah when I see you professional
bro I've saw you at the real Street Fest
which was like 2019 as well when we had
our real 92.3 Festival you performed at
and I was just like in awe bro yeah
could you be [ __ ] you'd be popping
and locking this [ __ ] you got every
movement that it reminded me of like
early Tech Nine like when I used to see
Tech Nine when I was a kid shout out to
Tech Nine is another one of the greats
Tech would have like a movement for
every [ __ ] like bar and I feel like
you're kind of similar
you are you high right now no it's
really the beats that uh that tell the
story yeah the song other movements you
know and the Beast we saw
you know like
like you know it'd be like yeah you know
what I'm saying my Beats really hit how
especially on stage I was gonna say how
like who would you say inspired your
like performance game or did you just
figure that [ __ ] out on your own I'm
still another game yeah
when I was coming up we used to watch a
lot a lot of artists before and one
artist in particular
let's just Busta Rhymes of course
he uh made an announcement you know I
said artist he needs to start performing
yep and I Tookie
and I started studying performers
and I I just developed my own style
get smart and bus is one of those ones
man for sure him and spliff star you
seen him live in person what's up it's a
[ __ ] fire so yeah yeah they are yeah
buses will go for sure they just they
just did a
where were they in La was a Hollywood
Bowl with nas it was Nas Buster Wu-Tang
Clan yeah shout out the bus
um shout out Kendrick though because you
spoke on him he's a great performer too
amazing
yeah did you go to the uh the this the
tour I mean he had like seven dates in
L.A it was good
it was dope Kendrick is also one of
those guys that can Captivate a crowd
without
you know I think some people mistake
screaming and jumping into a mosh pit
and crowd surfing and like just doing
wild [ __ ] on stage with like good
performing and like sure sometimes that
goes over well
but I think like your breath control how
you sound like how captivating you are
without doing all the crazy Antics on
stage to me is like very
more is more important right because
like anybody can like throw [ __ ] and
crowd Surf and yeah I'll be looking at
that like that's that's cool yeah it's
like cool it's like cool if you can't
perform when you're like rapping over
your [ __ ] track all right it's cool
it like wrapping over two tracks yeah
you're rapping over your two track but
you [ __ ] jumped off of a speaker and
you know sprained your ankle so
everyone's like yo you're a God bro